given that slavery in america is part
is part of its history
how do we incorporate into the calculus
of
um policy today
social discourse
what we learn in school
we can look at slavery in america we
could look at maybe more recent
things like uh in europe the
other atrocities the holocaust
how do we incorporate that in terms of
how we create policy how we treat each
other all those kinds of things
what is the calculus of integrating the
atrocities the injustices of the past
into the way we are today
that's a very complex question because
it's a it's a moral question at this
point
and a moral question long after the fact
um
i say at one point in the war in the
west that
the argument for instance on a
reparations now that goes on and and
it's not a not a fringe argument anymore
some people say oh you're pulling up
this fringe argument it really isn't i
mean every contender for the democratic
nomination for the
the presidency in 2020 was willing to
talk about the
possibility of reparations some very
eager
that this country in america
goes through that
entirely self-destructive exercise
um
i say that there's a there's a lot of
problems with this but if i could refine
it down to one thing i'd say this
um it's no longer about a wealth
transfer from one group of people who
did something wrong to another group of
people who were wronged it would have
been it would have been that could have
been that 200 years ago
today it's not even the descendants of
people who did something wrong giving
money to people who were the descendants
of people who were wronged
it's a wealth transfer from people who
look like people who did a wrong thing
in the past to another group of people
who resemble people who were wronged
that's impossible to do
i'm completely clear about this you
there is no
way
in which you could organize such a
wealth transfer
uh on moral or practical reasons america
is filled with people who are um
have the same skin color as us for
instance who have no connection to the
slave trade and should not be made to
pay money
to people who have some connection
and then the country is also filled with
ethnic minorities who have come after
slavery
who would not be
um due for any
reimbursement as it were
the problem the problem with this is
though is that
there are i'm perfectly open to the
possibility that there are
um
residual inequities that exist in
american life
and that's and that the consequences of
slavery could be one of the factors that
result from this
the thing is i don't think it's it's a
um
i don't think it's a single issue answer
i think it's a multi-dimensional issue
something like black underachievement in
america is obviously a multi-dimensional
issue
much of the left and others wish to say
it's not it's only about racism
and they can't answer why
asians who've arrived more recently
don't for instance get held down by
white supremacy but actually i say white
supremacy in
quotes obviously yeah but don't get held
back by it but actually flourish to the
extent that asian americans uh have a
higher household earnings and higher
house household mean um
uh
uh equity than home equity and so on
than than white americans
uh so i don't think that on the merits
the evidence is there that you know
racism is the explanation for black
ongoing black underachievement in some
sections of the black community in
america um it's obviously a part of it
could you say that even those things
like fatherlessness and
um
similar family breakdown issues
are a long-term consequence of it
possibly but it's it's being awfully
generous to people's
ability to make bad decisions
for instance how many generations off
the holocaust would you allow
people to claim that everything that
went wrong
in the jewish community was as a result
of the holocaust
i mean is there some kind of term limit
on this i would have thought so
and i think most people probably think
that's over
i think the details matter there the
and
um but it's very difficult
oh i enjoy swimming out in the ocean so
although i'm terrified of what's lurking
underneath in the darkness you're right
you're right to me
you